Joining me today is the libertarian
candidate for governor from the great
state of New York,
Larry Sharpe.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me.
Libertarian,
New York.
Yes.
Are you okay,
sir?
The issue to remember here is Keto
actually rated us 50th when it came to
freedom.
We beat California,
so he got you.
When you came,
you came here to California to see me.
Yes,
because we're better than you when it
comes to tyranny.
We got you that.
We got you.
You can't be this.
So yes,
this is a critical piece.
I'm glad I'm doing this.
It's the right answer because imagine
this,
if I make any impact in New York,
what does that say with country?
It shows that the impact of this race is
so important that if I can make anything
happen in New York state,
it will affect the rest of the nation
over night.
I want you to imagine for a second in my
race,
I just get 10 percent.
That will change how people think in New
York through throughout the entire
state.
It'll force republicans that actually
have to be Republicans,
Democrats,
because now the party will have an
actual voice.
So now when I go to Republicans and I
say,
you're supposed to be about small
government,
someone will listen.
When I go to Democrats and say,
you're supposed to be about civil
liberties.
Someone will listen.
It will force them to be better,
but I'm going to go one step further.
What if I actually beat the Republican
in New York State?
That's magical.
I beat the Republican New York state
politics works for the first two.
Two parties actually run everything so
republicans would officially be knocked
out.
So of course that we write the rules
overnight.
Of course they were the rules.
Of course,
if I know that.
Are you implying that New York state has
a corrupt assembling?
Oh,
come on,
come on.
We have office.
Emily.
Let's be clear.
Grew Assembly or insulting me now.
Most corrupt.
So now my point being,
it would then allow for third parties to
really exist in New York state and that
again would cross the nation.
But imagine if actually one,
if I actually went and I turned New York
state gold,
that would change the entire nation
overnight.
Overnight.
All the liberty leaning Republicans,
Democrats would come out of the woodwork
and be like,
we always love Larry Sharp and they
would all jump on board and,
and the Libertarian party will become
huge overnight.
This race has the most impact because
it's New York.
Okay.
So you are acknowledging this is an
uphill battle.
It's coming.
Yes.
And I got to tell you,
if it was six months ago,
I knew I could make impact that 10
percent I knew I could get.
I knew that six months ago.
What is the libertarian usually get in a
gubernatorial race?
One percent maybe I met.
That's a lot.
We rarely break 50,000
bucks.
If I go through,
we've ever bring him 2000 bucks.
What do you make of that?
Before we go specifically to your
candidacy?
Because one of my issues with the
Libertarians,
it's like as a party,
there's such disorganization.
You know,
I,
I want to talk a little bit about Gary
Johnson because I know you worked for
them.
And we're almost his VP choice,
a couple of people tried to beat him up,
but I'm a big fan we can get into to
some of that stuff and I've had on the
show and I think he's a good person.
I think he was a flawed candidate,
but just that the party itself seems to
be extremely disorganized and you know,
when they have these conventions and
it's like naked people and all this
naked guys,
naked guy and.
But that have been met naked guy.
I'm sure he's a great,
he's a great guy.
He's a nice guy,
but that,
that as a party,
there's been a lot of disorganization
here and I guess that when you were
making things about the individual,
it's hard to get people to come together
on a collective,
but what can you do?
What do you think?
That's a fair diagnosis?
Number one,
what I just laid out,
it's tough.
The system is set up against us,
right?
It's up against us to fail any third
party.
Right.
You.
Do you find any other third parties that
are great?
No,
but I least liked the idea of not on
board of the green stuff,
so I want them to.
I mean a lot of the third parties
collapse because the system is against
them,
but I say the same thing always the
panacea,
the cure,
all his victory when we begin to.
When people come up on our,
on our,
on our team,
a lot of the people who believe in us
don't join our party because of that
chicken and egg.
Yeah,
right.
The party isn't awesome because awesome
people aren't flooding to it because the
party is an awesome.
Therefore all some people are flooding
to it,
right?
It's a chicken and egg,
so once we become a real party where
people actually are saying,
wow,
these guys can win.
So when reasons why I'm reading this
libertarian,
right,
I'm not.
I'm not jumping ship and joining another
party and trying to go on some other
part of him running as a libertarian.
I'm doing it on purpose.
I want to show people a third party can
have impact and can win and joined the
third parties my candidacy is assuming I
do very well,
doesn't just a couple of Italians.
It helps any third party,
but obviously heavily my part.
It's what I care about,
but it will help others also.
So you're right,
it's a problem.
Of course it is,
but all the parties are a problem.
Look,
the Republicans and Democrats have Kooks
also,
right?
They have crazy.
There's no doubt about it.
It's just there's so few of us that I
will stand up and want to scrutiny.
I'm going to things that the things that
politicians who are Democrats,
Republicans have said on far worse than
Libertarians have set,
but it's whatever that the main that the
two old parties.
So they get a pass.
I'm not mad at it.
It's the way it is.
It's a burden that we have,
that I've accepted and I've taken on.
It's the burden I take on.
But here's the glory.
If I win this battle,
my victory sweeter because I had all the
burdens I'm find with it is what it is.
Yeah.
Alright.
So before we get into the specifics of
New York and what you are libertarian
principles are and things like that,
tell me a little bit about your history
because you are actually born and bred
in New York and you've got an
interesting history and were in the
marines and all sorts of stuff.
So it was.
So God gives me back.
I'll give you the short version.
I'm born in Manhattan.
I'm biracial parents in the sixties.
My mom gives me up for adoption because
she can't handle the issues of racial
issues in her family.
I'm very lucky to adopted very young.
I think I was six weeks old by a lovely
couple who took me to the Bronx,
a German immigrant and I'm her husband
who was in the army in Germany.
That's how we met her.
So I raised in the bronx for them around
um,
nine or 10 in that area.
11.
And at that point my mother had actually
divorced and met another man who was my
actual father who actually raised me and
taught me to be a man.
We moved to Long Island.
He died when I was around 12 years old.
When he passed.
It's just me and my mom.
My mom couldn't handle it.
She was really devastated by this.
Her family wasn't Germany.
She was here.
I was distant.
I was a young teenage boy trying to find
my way.
Also,
when I was 17,
I left and joined the Marine Corps.
The Marine Corps was there for about six
years,
seven years.
When I got out,
my mother had already collapsed.
She was initially they can to illegal
drugs and eventually illegal drugs.
She was arrested because the drug war,
she went to prison and Creighton Felon.
I got her out and try to put it back on
her feet.
I tried to help her too.
She left the prison with two garbage
bags.
That was what her life was,
so I helped her get back on her feet,
try to get a job.
I saw how hard it was for to get a job.
I mean,
she was always lying on every form
because of the new.
She was a felony.
They wouldn't hire her and when she was
working she had to always lie and she
was a hostage.
Basically I became an entrepreneur
because I didn't want my mom to be a
hostage,
so we started our own business.
Me and her and my Stepdad,
who was another man cheat,
she had married afterwards and so we
stopped,
started businesses together so that she
could be her own person and not be a
hostage.
That was our first business.
Um,
after that got up and running,
I left that,
had a bunch of sales jobs and then
decided to Uhm,
then decided to start my own business
again.
That business did not go well.
I sold that one off,
um,
that I went and got this business,
which I've had for 14 years.
I'm a consultant,
a trainer.
I've been an officer in a public company
twice.
I've taught in colleges.
I teach now at Baruch,
sometimes John Jay.
I've taught at the graduate level of,
uh,
as a guest instructor,
and Yale and Columbia.
So I've taught a lot.
I do a lot of negative coaching,
training,
leadership,
sales,
that kind of stuff.
And I'm an entrepreneur,
but doing it for 14 years and two years
ago I saw an opportunity to jump on
board the patreon party as a,
a VP nominees.
So I tried to get the VP slot.
I lost the bill.
Well by 30,
31 votes.
Not that anyone's counting.
Um.
And now I'm running for governor.
That was two years ago or that was in
2012?
Twenty 16.
That was 2016 was when I first came to
the party.
Okay.
I was not,
I was not really political at all when I
was a,
when I was a youngster.
Do you wanna hear the story?
Yeah.
When I'm interviewing you,
I write a lot with.
I think we're doing it.
I'm happy to the APP away for seven
hours the first time anyone's ever said
that to me.
I love to hear this story to your
audience.
Wants to hear my cold stuff.
I don't want.
Yes,
Yap away.
And they're like,
you know,
clicking off and we're going to watch.
I don't want to have a drink instead.
I don't know what it,
if that would make it better,
maybe.
Alright.
Let's see what happens with the story.
So,
um,
as a youngster,
I grew up in New York City and of course
Democrats or Republicans are evil.
How it works,
right?
You're evil because you have an art by
your name.
You're good because you with you by your
name.
Who was the mayor at the time?
This is where I think it was Ed Koch
cocktail because I loved the head coach.
So I grew up in long island,
but we were big but um,
but it wasn't about him.
It was about the party.
My Mom and dad strict Democrats.
That's who you are.
You voted Democrat because they look
good and Pumpkins were evil.
But when I joined the marine corps at
17,
at the Marine Corps is a very
conservative branch when it comes to the
branches and most of my friends and
people I know in leaders that are
respected,
they were mostly conservative
Republicans.
Uh,
Ronald Reagan was my first commander in
chief.
So I think I kind of became a republican
as a,
as a team.
And as a young 20 something,
I became more of a Republican.
So I kind of shifted back,
I was never part of a party and they
only voted in the presidential elections
because it was absentee.
I wasn't,
I was always overseas so I wouldn't be a
male,
so I didn't even register locally to do
the local elections.
So can we pause there for one sec
because you mentioned you're biracial
and I hate making anything about race
because we're so overly racialized now
and identity politics and all this,
but I think that a certain amount of my
own is when they hear you say that.
All right.
So you were,
you were,
uh,
Ronald Reagan was your commander in
chief and you were identifying as a
Republican back then as a black man.
Yup.
Um,
you know,
I've had many black conservatives not
here,
some of whom I considered great friends,
like Larry Elder and I bet this was the
eighties,
Thomas Soul on and many or no.
So that's why I wanted to ask you about
that.
What,
what was it like then to take that
political,
very political,
if that made any sense.
Like I wasn't talking about things I
did,
but even internally for you,
I didn't care to before too.
I didn't care if you don't care now.
I didn't care that I don't care.
Now I am who I am.
I believe what I believe.
And you like it or you don't.
And that's how it is.
I didn't care that either.
Right?
So I didn't really care to be fun with
you.
Some people thought I was crazy.
My parents were,
have been insane,
but whatever.
I didn't care.
I didn't talk about it much.
It wasn't.
I was worried about,
you know,
chasing girls at 19,
20 years old was being a marine.
I was,
I wasn't worried about it.
It wasn't part of my life to be before
with you.
I look back now and I wish it was.
I wish I had known more stuff then,
but I was a young guy trying to figure
out to be a man.
I wasn't really thinking about that very
much.
So that's why eventually the nineties I
went to,
I went to Perot because I just didn't
want the ares of the DS.
Then I went to Nader 2000 because I
didn't want the RS and the DS.
I knew that the RS and the Ds were the
same.
There was no difference.
I knew they were all putting my friends
in jail.
I knew they will.
All the one drugs and the war on terror
wasn't going to stop that.
That's going to be bad no matter what I
did.
Excuse me.
So I just.
And again,
if you would've asked me what was Perot,
what was it?
What was a nadir?
His policies.
I couldn't have told you.
I just knew they weren't the mainstream
and therefore they have a good enough
for me.
And again,
people thought I was crazy and I didn't
care.
So finally,
in 2008,
I was considering not voting at all
anymore.
I was really finished.
I was like,
they'll do care.
It doesn't matter of running a business.
I'm gonna,
run my business,
make my money,
become a bazillionaire and who cares
who's in charge because I'll run them
because I'll have all the money.
That was my logic.
It doesn't for so are the eight.
When Obama came,
I thought,
okay,
this is different.
He's the city Guy Black.
This is the guy.
He's different.
He speaks differently.
People are excited.
All right.
You know what?
Maybe this is the guy and I,
I had hope I,
I bought the hope and change.
I bought it and when I address it before
you added sort of a libertarian
awakening,
right?
Actually I,
I,
this is,
I was having libertarian awakening,
but that sort of overrode it.
But I gotta tell you how I became that.
I became a libertarian,
not through politics.
I came to trying it through Robert
Ringer.
Robert Ringer.
I don't think Robert Ringer is a
business guy.
He's a subjectivist and he wrote many
books looking out for number one to be
a,
not to be intimidated,
nothing happens.
Uh,
unless something moves action.
He talks about how to brand yourself.
He talks about how to be successful in
business in life.
I was a trainer as well.
I said there now,
he was one of my mentors.
I don't know him personally,
but I've read his books.
I was part of his website,
so I knew who he was,
so he.
He got me into reading and rent.
I didn't come to libertarianism through
politics.
I came into business.
I'm a business guy,
so I was reading atlas shrugged because
he said we that the shrugged not because
some political I did.
I didn't know who Ron Paul was.
Doesn't eight.
I had no idea.
I wasn't political.
I was a business guy.
The only reason why I care about Obama's
because he was so different.
It got my attention.
So again,
I didn't really understand his policies,
if that made me sense.
I just thought he's different.
He's not them.
It can't be worse.
That was my thought process.
So as I'm moving towards objectivism in
that regard,
I'm not an objectivist and I'd never
been one,
but some of the market ideas made sense
to me.
The idea of Austrian economics made
sense to me.
I didn't know it was Austrian economics
though,
because I'd never read freedom and I'd
never read those.
I didn't know.
I read Robert Ringer and he had told me
what his,
his views,
so I got things secondhand through him,
so I was already teaching.
I was teaching postindustrial
leadership.
Obviously she'd buy in.
I was teaching sales is not about
forcing someone to do something,
getting to do it.
I was teaching volunteerism,
not knowing what it was called or what
it was.
I was already doing it in my own
business.
So anyway,
I was.
I was having that change so it doesn't
fall and about 2010.
Anyway,
that was happening already.
So it changed my business model and
doing it already.
After crash it,
I had to jump into it a lot because I
was crushed,
crushed,
devastated me.
So anyway,
I,
I'm,
I think Obama's great.
After the first year I realize he's no
different again.
I'm finished.
I'm like,
it's over until 2012.
I hear Gary Johnson speak and people
say,
well,
Gary John,
he's an awesome speaker.
No,
but he was a business guy.
I'm a business guy.
I could hear him.
I couldn't hear anyone else because I
didn't care.
I could only hear the person who I was
identified with him self made man and
growing a business identify with Gary
Johnson.
I still do,
and so when he decided to talk I said,
oh,
I get it.
And I came to the part because of him,
but we forward.
I didn't join the party still right
away.
I'd never done a part of my life.
I'd never done a party,
but at this point I thought,
you know what?
I'm going to go to the meetings and
never been to a party meeting before and
I went to the meetings and when I went
to Libertarian party meetings as odd as
they were and they are odd,
it was still just regular people.
It wasn't crazy.
It was regular people,
business owners,
people who wanted to see some change
identified quickly with them and I
joined.
So I joined the Party in 2012 and that's
when I became a libertarian.
But when I joined the party I hadn't
read.
I hadn't read for.
I didn't read any of them had had.
I didn't even know them.
So that's when I joined them.
I began looking around and then I then I
read the law [inaudible] my favorite of
all them was his boss,
yet it's my favorite.
That was the simplest and the one that
identified with the most still my
favorite,
but I read all the rest.
Also.
I began to read them.
Right.
I read the word road to serfdom.
I began to read those afterwards,
but they were easy for me to understand
that people,
they tease me.
The Larry,
you've been in the movement so short,
short time,
but you can.
You can talk with the principals.
I've been teaching them for 14 years but
not under the name,
right.
In a different world,
so it was very easy to adapt and to
bring those,
those things to bear.
So bought for Gary Johnson in 2012 and I
support his candidacy completely in
2016.
I was running around doing debates in
his stead.
I was on TV instead for him and then he
wanted I would do so I jumped through
hoops for them because I wish he was a
president now when she was.
So I don't want to Belabor the point
where Gary,
I voted for Gary,
I did a video in the summer before the
election of why it would be great to
support him even though he wasn't a
perfect candidate,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But he,
he had a couple of gaps that were pretty
bad and I also,
I don't even blame him for them in a
certain way because it was the only to
your point,
it was the only way he could get
pressed.
Like the only time they talked about him
was Aleppo apps or the other moment
where he couldn't name a leader that he
respected.
But the one,
the one policy point that really
bothered me with him and I don't know,
maybe maybe we don't see eye to eye on
this,
is that he wanted the baker to bake the
cake.
Well,
let me touch to two of those things.
The first thing is every problem that
Gary Johnson had is fixed with good
advisors.
Everyone,
yeah.
Repaired was good advisors.
Every problem you had,
you get him.
Good advisors,
fixed Clinton and trump.
I don't care who you put in front of
them,
it's irrelevant.
Who Do you put?
Whatever team you put in for them.
They have character flaws.
Johnson doesn't have that.
So you as a human being,
he's.
I'm telling you,
I don't have to tell you,
but I mean I sat there with him for an
hour and some time off camera and I
thought this is a decent human hundred
percent.
Yes,
I'm with you.
So if I had a choice,
I'd rather be president now without
question of course.
But the second was to bake the cake.
He didn't do a good job explaining what
he really meant and I let me try to
explain it to make it clearer.
He understood the cultural aspects of
this as do I as a person of color,
right.
There is a.
we've had literally decades,
if not centuries of state sponsored
segregation,
punishment by gender,
by,
by race,
by sexual preference.
That is still in the psyche of the
American.
It feels terrible to do what is right,
if that makes any sense.
Yeah,
it feels terrible and while the person
goes,
but it's wrong.
I get it,
emotion and culture matter and what he
was trying to get at,
which is my policy.
It was to find a good solid middle
ground.
I do not want a bigger to make a cake
for someone he doesn't want a make a
cake for.
That's his labor.
Having to do it for someone that's wrong
should never happen.
So here is the.
Here is the good compromise.
If a baker or anyone,
anyone creates a product and puts it
into the retail market,
whether that be online or on a shelf in
a store.
If a person gets your product and puts
it there,
he must allow anyone who has the current
two that he wants to purchase that
product.
So so far,
yeah.
I'm with you so far.
Now that you could say,
and purists will say no Larry.
He can say no to anyone.
So that would be the set of people who
would like to go back and reverse this
64 civil liberties.
I'm saying just let now if the person
is,
I want that cake off the shelf and
literally you're Jewish and he's a Nazi
with a swastika.
On his arm,
you must say,
take it,
you have the money to take my ticket out
of here.
So he told them.
He then says,
I now want you to put on it so and so.
No,
you can refuse that service because now
that's not retail.
That's you doing a service for that
individual.
You should absolutely be able to say,
no,
I will not put anything on that cake at
all.
That's the way it is.
That's why I made it for anyone.
If you want it,
take it.
That's not good enough for you.
Have a nice day.
That is my compromise and I think that's
what Gary Johnson actually meant to say
because if you're hurt the way you said
it,
and when I spoke to him about it,
he understood what I was saying.
Then I wish I.
I'm because I'm with you on what you
just said this.
I'm with you.
I'm and I want to.
I tried to defend him with that,
but it didn't come across right and I
think he did that and it because for him
to be fired,
I'm going to defend them and defend
them.
Often.
It's emotional for him,
so it didn't come across well.
It's emotional for me to write.
I know what it's like.
I know personally what it's like to be.
To be ignored in a restaurant.
I know what that's like.
Black people don't.
It feels terrible now to be forward.
I think that's a good compromise.
Okay,
so I'm with you on that.
I'm glad you cleaned it up for yourself
and I'm glad you cleaned it up for Gary
because I,
I feel kind of [inaudible] I know he's a
decent guy and I don't like giving him
crap for it.
What would you say to the part of the
libertarians that want to go that extra
step and say either the 64 act should be
repealed because we don't need these
laws anymore or that no,
you just.
Even if it's just the same old product
on your shelf and you just don't like
the way somebody looks because you are a
bigot,
it's still your stuff and and what,
what do you say?
They are theoretically correct and
realistically wrong,
and if they don't accept the compromise,
they're going to get worse.
This is the problem that a lot of the
more hard libertarians don't know.
Is that clear?
I love them.
I want them in the party.
They are critical.
They are the backbone of the party.
There are our harshest and most powerful
activists.
We need them.
Yeah,
and you believe that that's not based in
bigotry.
That's no,
that's an adult,
but that's an important distinction.
It's based on righteousness and they're
right.
The problem is if you don't take that
first step,
you will get nothing but not just
nothing.
Those people who keep voting are going
to keep voting our rights away.
They do it every single year.
They keep voting our rights away as we
accept everything or nothing.
It isn't nothing.
It's worse.
Give us the compromise.
That makes sense.
They'll see the world doesn't end.
They'll see this not a zombie
apocalypse,
and then we can move to the next level.
Is that part of the problem of being
sort of an outlier party because the
libertarian party that's existed for a
long time and it's an on all the ballots
but never really breaks any major
threshold.
That part of it is you get too caught up
in the purity test.
Now all parties do in a way,
but do,
but I think for the third party,
if there's maybe a little trickier and
maybe for libertarians more than als,
because if you're really basing it on
the individual,
the purity test is pretty freaking high,
is what you're going to make that very
clear.
You.
You look at Democrats,
Republicans now they're not actually
parties,
their tribes,
and I mean that literally their tribes.
You have Weber's the king of the tribe
at the moment.
The will of the king is the platform,
right?
So whatever trump says,
that's the platform,
right?
Assuming that Bernie's still top of the
Democrats will be is whoever is right,
then that's the platform.
Whoever the person is,
that's the platform.
The platform is whoever is on top of the
part of what you want.
They don't argue as much,
which is why they close ranks,
right?
So easily.
Liquidated probably is different.
It actually has an ideology.
I can call myself king a libertarian if
I want to.
That's not going to go well at all and
no one's gonna.
No one's gonna buy it.
That's not going to work.
They want to change that language.
That is not gonna work at all.
I can say it if I want to,
so what I'll get laughed out of the
party because it's not about me.
It's about audiology,
which is why we argue to be forward with
you.
I'm happy we argue I am because it makes
us a better party.
It makes us clearer.
It actually makes policy easier for us
because we don't look at Paul's of that.
Oh,
this policy fits this.
No,
it's based upon based upon audiology,
so I'm actually happy that we argue.
I wish we would argue so much as a
publicly.
Right.
That's the part that drives me crazy,
that we do it so publicly and that we
fight so hard,
but I'm glad we have an idea.
Again,
I don't know that it's that you guys are
doing.
It's so public.
It's just that that's the only time that
you're seeing in public.
It's a bit of an important distinction.
So when you say that the way you just
described the cake situation is
basically your view on government in
general,
because again,
this is where you can go to a
libertarian that really isn't an endcap
or the people you described as the
backbone that it basically you're sort
of.
I guess I would just.
I mean this is what I would say
classical liberal is really,
it's just that where the rubber meets
the road,
you understand that there has to be some
level of government.
Is that sort of your guiding principle?
Like my,
my north star is a full voluntary
society.
That's my north star.
I would love to have a total and fully
voluntary society.
How do you define what that is?
Where,
where government is even voluntary.
That would be amazing.
But to be fair with you,
our nation is no where near.
I mean that's.
I modeled was asking you what I'd like.
I'd like.
I'd like a world where leprechauns ride
unicorns at the moment it's the same
thing and it just doesn't exist.
Yeah,
it's,
we're nowhere near there and one reason
why I'm attacking New York state as,
as hard as I am campaigning so hard is
if we can just stop the bleeding.
If we can just stop it from shifting lap
right now,
and if you know,
we're talking in New York state about
giving teachers the right to tell law
enforcement if a child is dangerous so
they can now confiscate that child's
parents.
Guns were talking about that now.
That's the new them's on New York state
where Joe wed going so far away.
It's not even funny.
So talk about this.
It's imaginary.
I just want to turn it around.
Let me do that.
If I do that,
we've got to shout to get in there.
I probably will never see a voluntary
society in my life.
I probably won't.
It'd be awesome if I could,
but can I turn us around so we're facing
it at least that I can do that I can
absolutely do and I can do it in my
lifetime.
I can do it in New York state and new in
the country.
We can do that.
So with that in mind,
and when you talk about the principles
of the party,
how do you generally decide what the
right amount of government is then?
I mean you're,
you want to be in the government so the
government has to do something.
Is it,
is it really just on a case by case
basis of both the lightest touch?
It's always okay.
Do you.
Have you ever run for office?
Not yet.
Alright.
One of the reasons why it's so hard.
There's many reasons why one is raising
money,
obviously the one's time,
but the third one is understanding all
the policies and when you begin to
understand how much government intrusion
in our life,
it's depressing and I mean that truly
most people have no idea how much
government in truth in our life and how
much ask you hurts.
It's depressing.
I've policy coals.
Every my policy team,
we were on the phone using anywhere from
an hour to two hours every week and
discussing policy issues.
Sometimes I'm depressed when I'm done
because it's so bad.
There's no good answer because
government problem has been solved with
government bandaid,
which has been solved by government
bandaid,
so if you pull off government bandaid,
you've three more broken bandaids
underneath it that sometimes make things
worse.
Sometimes taking government off makes it
worse because of three more band aids
that are all terrible.
Sometimes you have to just say,
I can't touch that.
I just have to let it stay there.
And you have someone who goes,
but Larry,
that's wrong.
That righteous.
That's easy.
We have to stop it.
There are 3000 things I have to fix.
Some I just can't put on my radar.
So yes,
it's always case by case to try to fix
government is a Herculean task that no
one could do.
What do you make of the states like New
York that have gotten so away from the
ideas?
Forget the policies,
forget the 3000 problems.
Right?
But just the basic ideas of why liberty
and individualism and limited government
and your own capacity to control your
property and things of that nature that
the states that have gotten so far away
from that.
I mean,
that's,
I guess that's why you're running in the
first.
It's culture.
People ask all the time,
they say,
you know,
what are your first hundred days and to
be like,
and what are you gonna Change?
They think I'm going to walk into New
York state as governor and wave my magic
wand or bring up my guy.
I'm the kid now.
Everything changes.
Of course not.
I wouldn't want to.
If I could write,
I can't and I wouldn't want to if I
could.
That kind of fast change makes people
afraid and here's the reason to be
clear.
It's all about fear.
When people are afraid,
they make bad decisions,
that simply human nature.
Fear makes bad decisions.
Fear is the root of aggression.
Government at the end of his law,
at the end of every law was a couple of
minor exceptions,
but almost every law,
the of everyone is a guy or a Gal with a
gun put you in a cage,
which means by default law is force.
Government is force.
Now,
should we never used for us?
No,
no.
You can use force to defend your rights
property.
He didn't use force,
but when you are afraid,
you're first step is force,
so when you are afraid,
you're first step is government and
that's what happens in the states like
New York,
California.
The first answer is government.
It's the old,
there oughta be a law.
I don't like this.
They want to be a law.
This is wrong.
There were to be a law and that culture
has been part of us for at least 50
years,
if not more.
I mean just decades upon decades has
been that way.
I see the same thing,
right?
Oh,
someone's smoking in front of me to
think the same way until I was
enlightening.
Go.
Oh no,
that's a bad idea.
Why would I do that?
But I thought I was righteous and the
thing that we have to remember is we
also idealize the idea of democracy.
We idolize when we voted,
there's a law.
The story I love,
I tell this whole time,
I was speaking to an Ip attorney,
intellectual property attorney,
and she was talking to me about
intellectual property law and I'm making
this up.
I don't remember the actual rules.
So she said something,
and again,
I'm not a lawyer,
I'm going to just say numbers.
So we have some,
you know,
after the copyright law is 95 years
after the person's death.
It was something like that and I said 95
years after her death,
she goes,
yeah.
I said,
what a terrible law.
It's horrible.
She said,
yeah,
but it's a law.
I know.
I'm not doubting that your lawyer.
I'm sure you know the law.
I'm sure that's true and it's a bad law.
She said,
but you understand we had to change our
laws to match international law.
So now we match international law.
And I said,
great,
that's a really bad international law.
She looked like she was angry at me
because in her eyes,
law equals righteousness that the same.
There's no difference.
International law equals extra
righteousness.
It's just,
it's amazing.
So she was mad at me because in her eyes
I was a heretic.
That's how she saw me.
Now she didn't make the law.
It wasn't her idea.
She was not congress congressperson who
did it.
No,
she's simply a priest of the law and I'm
a heretic.
And she was mad at me,
they might think,
well that's when we lawyers guide
department of buildings in New York.
I'm talking to him,
this guys educated,
smart,
credentialed.
I say to him,
I say,
I'm,
I'm kinda curious about the landmarking
law and if you may not know landmarking
in New York City is when you can
actually,
you know,
kind of a community can say this
property's landmarked and now nothing
can be done to that property unless the
community agrees.
Lots of people want it.
They want to protect their community so
that developers can come in and do it
all the time.
Is that just for a building or is that
actually.
Can it be for like a group of buildings
are a part of thing?
I think it's one building at a time.
I'm pretty sure it's one property at a
time.
Okay.
But actually doing groups,
but I think it's one property at a time.
So you can also have that happen to you
without you wanting the community can
just landmark your property.
That can happen.
And it has happened a couple times.
So now documentary landmarks your
property.
So I totally,
I said,
how is that okay?
I don't understand how that works.
And the guy told me,
Larry,
it's the same lower use for when that
building is condemned.
And I said,
ah,
that makes sense.
Right?
Condemning makes sense.
If a building collapses,
thousands could die.
Totally makes sense.
I see a victim got that law.
I'm in good when it comes to
landmarking,
where's victim?
He went,
no,
no.
You don't understand.
It's the same law we use.
I get that.
Totally get it.
Where's the victim laterally?
It's St Law because in his eyes again,
law equals righteousness.
This is the mindset we have in for many
Americans and we have to break that
mindset.
The idea that just because it's a law,
does it make it righteous?
By default,
lots of laws have been bad and been
overturned in a wrong.
Lots of them are low,
doesn't make it righteous,
but we say it will be voted
now.
Becomes okay now.
Great.
I vote.
You give me all your stuff.
Awesome.
I guess you have to be very self now.
You can have all my stuff.
Well there we go.
But.
But I voted so we've got a problem.
I try to tell people when I go through
New York state,
I'm trying to change the concept of
right now,
government,
most of the time it's just this.
It enforces the will of the majority.
I want government's primary purpose to
be to instead defend the rights of the
individual specifically when you have
localization from the local believers
who will pop up because local bullies
will always pop up.
But now local bullies are validated by
the big government because you voted so
local.
Bullies have more power than ever.
Instead,
the state government should be defending
the individual against local police
against him.
That domain against property tax hikes,
against speeding tickets that are $405
for a speeding ticket.
This would be defending them against the
local bullies.
But we're not.
All right,
so let's talk about some of the unique
issues in New York because although a
lot of states have,
you know,
a big city and then a rural area,
New York really has it.
And I remember growing up in New York
where there were always,
you know,
I'd read Newsday was the long island
paper and they were always talking about
the fights between New York City and
Albany because we have this huge rural
upstate area.
The upstate area right now is extremely
economically depressed.
I went to Suny Binghamton.
I know the area pretty well.
Um,
how do you deal with someone that wants
to be the governor of the state,
the chief executor of the state.
How do you deal with having,
what is it?
Something around like 8 million people
and a half million people in New York
City.
Sixty dollars million in metro area.
If few includes pots,
Connecticut,
New Jersey,
Long Island parts of a Westchester
County.
So it's about 16 million metro area.
It's New York City is the largest city
in America.
And by far it's over double La.
La is the second and it's over double.
So it is by far the largest city in
America.
There are more people in one of our
boroughs then at least 10 states,
just one of our girls.
There are more people in New York City
than there are in 40 states.
That's how big we are.
We're massive there.
Are there,
um,
but not just that New York City is very
unique in that about one third of its
population is not born in the country
and another about one third is not born
in India,
in the city.
So we are literally a magnet for talent,
which is why because we're a magnet for
talent and we have 60 million people who
are possible candidates for,
you know,
customers,
candidates for,
um,
for jobs we can basically be a communist
state and still function,
right?
Because we have so many advantages.
Our,
our advantages are so high.
It's people say how can you possibly
work in New York City?
There's so many advantages and we have
the massive vantage of finance.
I mean finance is a massive put up.
New Exam.
Manhattan's infrastructure is huge.
So basically the machine just keeps
churning.
That's correct.
Through people,
through jobs,
through everything else.
So the more we,
the more you push out,
the more you bring in.
Absolutely.
So the,
the,
so it just keeps happening.
The rest of the state is not that way at
all.
Less than New York,
central,
New York,
northern,
uh,
northern country,
southern tier,
Long Island,
very different,
different.
And one of the things I'm doing is I'm
trying to show them something very
important.
This has to come down to localization.
It's making government smaller in
general,
right?
Neil says several problems as you talked
about the city from the rest,
which is very different,
but also 70 percent of New Yorkers don't
vote in certain counties upstate.
Only one in seven votes they've given
up.
They've just given up.
It's learned helplessness,
right?
They just totally given up.
And we have over 100,000
New Yorkers leaving our state every
single year over 100,000,
but a million in the last eight years
walking away.
Now you say,
Oh my God.
And walking away New York City must be
getting killed.
No nukes.
He's about imagine,
same or higher,
all coming from upstate western New
York,
all coming from,
of leaving his youth flight.
All our young people are gonna.
Educate and leaving or leaving an
educating someplace else,
not coming back.
Is that mostly a tax issue?
I'm sorry?
Is that mostly a tax issue or to drive?
It's everything.
It's high cost of living,
new opportunities.
Those who,
these combined,
but it can't change because we have a
thing called unfunded mandates and is
devastating our state and what does that
mean?
That means in a given county up to 95,
sometimes over 100 percent of the budget
is already mandated by Albany or capital
or by DC.
So who's running the county?
Someone else's.
Why show up?
We have local cities and towns where we
don't have enough people to fill all the
billets for people.
Show up.
Okay.
I guess you're the chair.
I'm the vice chair.
You're cemetery because we're here.
Right,
and no one else shows up ever.
Unless they're angry,
so angry will show up against them.
It by default becomes US versus them.
They go in their backroom,
crate their edx and announced the people
and we have local tyrants,
but more importantly,
how do I can think that in my county
when I have to buy all these things as
mandated by the state and by the federal
government had to raise money somehow.
Only two ways.
There's a loophole in the old state.
When it comes to property taxes,
every.
The tax has to be voted on by the
people.
Property tax?
No,
only by the council.
So officially our governor will tell you
there's a two percent cap in property
tax,
but there's an exception if it's an
emergency.
So they go behind closed doors,
declared emergency and raise property
taxes nine percent.
What do they count as an emergency?
I need money.
We on the money,
the unfunded mandates go past our
budget.
So two choices.
Option one is that property taxes option
to use law enforcement as a profit
center.
So now that parking thing that was 100
bucks is out there in a bucks speeding
ticket.
That was 50 bucks is now 500 bucks.
It's so bad that a lot of places in New
York state,
they don't even want you to come to
court anymore,
so when you get a bunch of tickets they
asked just sell the tickets off to
collect agency,
get thirty cents of a dollar and
everyone your credit because they don't
wanna waste your time to bring you in
for court because you might not be able
to pick.
They don't care if you pay.
Yeah,
they're actually getting the money from
the collect agency so they get a bunch
of tickets.
Collect agency gets it.
You,
you go to court whenever you want with
them.
So.
Okay.
So hearing everything you just said
there,
that's like one
of those things you that it makes so
much sense.
It shows what the glut is,
the middle management,
corruption and greed and all that stuff.
Not even close to that.
No,
no.
I know.
Well,
let's just pause for one second though
because because as you're saying it,
I'm thinking,
man,
this is the type of stuff that I think
if people really understood they would
be pissed about,
but it's like one of those things that
as a candidate explaining this to people
and getting people to be like,
yes,
it is the backdoor deals.
This is like one of those issues where
it's not easy to put the bumper sticker
on and get people to get excited about.
It's not,
I need to build that wall and whatever
that.
Right.
Exactly.
Now to build that wall that he dot.
Yeah,
exactly.
so pop music.
I knew New York and saved main street
had been working pretty well.
I had a couple of those sayings was
saying which one actually lands.
We're using those right now.
Seeing how they work,
but yeah,
I mean this is a big problem.
Of course people don't show up.
Of course you will.
Don't vote.
I think changes,
right?
But here's another problem.
We have counties where you have one
third of the population of Medicaid,
one third of Medicare and the dwindling
population.
The tax burden going up,
New York state has a budget of about
$170,000,000,000
and compared to California,
I'm sure the title however I'm going to.
I'm going to.
I'm going to compare that to other
state.
Florida,
Florida has more people than us.
Half the budget now.
The argument I always get is,
but lowery,
New York is expect or something on a
services.
Then why a hundred thousand $100 leaving
every year and half of them are going to
Florida.
So many New Yorkers are leaving our
state that in the Carolinas they have a
name for us.
They call us halfbacks,
Florida and halfway back,
so we're going to Carolina as we'll call
it,
half bath.
That's how common it is.
Now we're running ever.
Every time I do an event,
I asked two questions.
Question number one.
I say,
how many people here I think about
leaving New York hands always go up and
they look around like,
wow,
there was only one.
No,
half the room in every place I go.
I go to a college,
I go to a diner,
I go to a Vfw,
is matter where I go,
I go to American Legion,
I go someplace,
boom.
Half the hands go up there all ready to
leave.
Most of them us somehow trap trap
because of kids shot because of job
traffic,
because their properties in the water,
they're trapped,
but as soon as they can get that next
level,
they are gone.
Huge problem.
Secondly,
I asked all the time is how many of you
have not voted in the past two election
cycles and those go up.
What does that mean?
It means I'm drawing the people in
because I'm worried about the most
important piece here and that is about
impact what you do.
How do I win this thing?
This is a winnable race.
Six months ago I wouldn't have said
that.
Now I know there's at least a four
person race.
It's going to be his majesty,
King Cuomo.
He will be running for sure the
communists.
How Hok is room for the winning party,
the sacrificial lamb.
We're run by Republicans who cannot win,
just fighting for second place.
Who is Manara?
He's a downstate Republican.
They pick two downstate republicans to
run for governor and the governor.
Clearly they surrendered.
Let's just get as much as we can.
New York City and try to get second
place they've surrendered and then at
least four.
It's possible the act from sex and the
city.
Nixon will stay in.
Maybe.
I don't know if she will after she loses
to a.
She may stay.
I may not.
So two maybe and then maybe someone else
a minor out of Syracuse may not as
independent as possible.
I could have six,
but at least for New York state's a
plurality state means all I need is more
than the rest.
There are about $18 million.
19 million New Yorkers.
About 12 men that are eligible to vote.
Only about four to 5 million every vote.
One point 5 million votes.
And the governor.
Thirty percent.
I'm the governor,
Larry.
That's huge.
It is.
But Gary,
John's got a 175,000
votes in my state in 2016.
He was there for five minutes.
He showed up,
waved and walked away,
and it was 175,000
people who said,
I'm so sick and tired out,
vote for Gary Johnson.
I'll do it.
I live in this state.
I campaign the state.
I've raised more money than everyone
except for the governor.
You tell me I can't get 10 times that
five times that even.
Of course I can,
but more importantly,
you have three other people have to get
three types.
Number one,
unhappy Democrats,
Republicans,
tons of them,
but they're not my number one because
many of them will still go back to old
ways because most people who vote often,
usually both because of fear not because
of hope.
This little free,
the other guy might win that.
Most of them was going to go back
through old ways.
I get that,
but some of them won't take whatever I
can yet,
but the next one is the single issue
voter.
The person who cares,
but only one thing and one thing only.
I bring up many of these issues of the
vaping industry,
right in New York state is trying to
crush the vaping industry.
I don't know why they can't stand it.
Trying to destroy the vaping industry.
Silly.
Why would you?
Well,
if you're a vaper,
that's important.
You have your own.
If you own a vape shop,
that's your livelihood.
I could be saying,
I want to support the industry and a
kick puppies in the streets filed with
the public thing.
Just really care about it.
It's all so issues like that,
right?
People who father's rights,
people have been crushed by family law,
have an entire policy for fixing.
The family court system has been
completely revamped their fathers,
at least a million who've been crushed
and destroyed by the family court system
in New York state.
I mean just devastated.
They have higher suicide rates.
They've been their families ever jail,
horribleness,
right?
These people care about that issue.
I will fix that.
In Law.
I'm the only ones supporting the
industry.
The only to my family law.
These people vote for me because that's
what they care about.
People who in New York state who've
gotten Duis,
three of us are more and they lose their
license in perpetuity,
no matter what.
There are some people who've paid the
time in jail,
done role,
and I've been clean for five years.
Clean.
You have straighten your life out.
You've done your time,
you've paid your time in jail,
and you brought your license back,
and if they leave New York state,
then the state won't get my license
because it was revoked.
They may never drive again.
No,
you're not giving them a chance to be a
functioning member.
They can't.
That has to go and people say,
but lottery,
why would you support these industries?
We're number one of these issues.
Why?
It's right.
I'm a libertarian.
That's what we do.
I am righteous.
Of course I libertarians always,
and it's the thing,
most of them,
they'll get.
Libertarians always have the moral high
ground.
Always the act like we don't,
but we always do.
I know that.
So I take the moral high ground.
It's mine.
I own it,
so I take it and it's right.
I'm in the pocket of big Dui pocket.
Of course not right?
It shows people that I care,
that it makes sense,
and they know that when I get into
power,
I'm still going to support his people.
I'm not going.
I'm not in it for the money.
These people vote tons of these issues.
They will jump on board and they will
vote,
but more than that,
there are 8 million New Yorkers who
don't vote.
They vote because of hope.
Bernie taught us this and trump told us
this.
Trump gave,
gave the right hope.
Bernie gave the left hope.
Now,
if the Democratic Party wasn't so
broken,
Bernie would have been the nominee and
it would've been hope versus hope and
hope.
One,
I think you've been corrupt.
Yes.
I don't know if it's broken or corrupt.
It was intentional.
They were both either,
but it would have been hope versus hope.
Hope one hope gets people out of their
bed and stopped playing video games and
show up.
How do you make that happen?
By having events,
I'm doing events all the time.
People are showing up to my events who
didn't vote,
which means they will show up at the
polling booth trumpet.
Brian told us this.
I'm copying.
Then it's working.
Look,
look what got you here.
I mean your guys.
I started seeing it more and more and
more on twitter.
Next thing I know,
I think you tweeted at me or one of your
guys tweeted at me and we made it
happen.
Absolutely on,
yes,
but here's the next four pieces.
Now.
Now if I just get 10 percent of the 8
million,
800,000,
I'm halfway there.
Tell us what.
I'll pick up.
I'm the governor.
I get 20 percent.
It's a blowout.
This is a winnable race.
There were four arenas.
Anyone that has to win on to get elected
for first one,
social media.
Six months ago I would have thought I
could never win because Cuomo has so
much more money than I have,
right?
I thought,
no way I could win,
but he.
His social media isn't competent.
We are winning on social media that is
on mobile and this is proof of it.
We are killing it in social media.
We are winning hands down,
but that's just one.
The second one is traditional media.
This one I struggle in.
Tourism is tough for me.
They go for the popular.
Cynthia Nixon was popular or the
governor.
They go with the tried and true.
It's hard to get it and then I live in
New York City,
New York City.
Something's always going on Tuskegee
coverage,
so the to get round that I'd be going
upstate western New York.
Smaller towns where that to Joyce's,
right?
Some some guy lost his cow or not.
I was coming to town shower,
so I've been doing that so I get a lot
of local media,
but I've also learned that local media
also often overlaps.
They also have social media presence.
Some of the writers are shared among
different papers,
so I'm getting a lot of press in the
local paper,
so I'm doing better traditional media.
I don't know if I can actually win it.
Maybe,
maybe not,
but that's one.
That's one issue that I'm fighting on.
I'm trying new tactics to win on that
one.
The next one's events,
as I talked about right now,
no one else is doing events.
I'm the only one doing it.
I'm the only one out shaking hands and
kissing babies and meeting people and
I'm winning events like there's no
tomorrow.
I'm winning an events.
Right.
The issue is they will eventually begin
doing events when they do will I will.
I have ramped up to speed or not some
questionable on those two.
The last one's debates.
If you see me debate,
I have no problem debating.
I will crush them on debates,
so I will.
When social media and debates.
The question is can I,
when traditional media and our events,
if I win three out of four,
I'm the governor.
Now.
You said you said a key if there,
which was if you debate what's the
debate situation for the rebates because
traditionally for always in the dates
they were in 2014,
2010 traditionally are to be
Libertarian,
green,
Democrat,
Republican,
so odds are debates as a very high and
they keep you in the debate regardless
of polling.
After that one,
once I ran,
it's for all the way across,
but they probably only do one to two or
three,
but who wanted to be the only.
Oh,
that's the debate in October one and
October.
It's all man.
So that's like,
that's like the show up.
That's it.
Win,
lose or draw right there.
Yeah.
I don't mind it.
I liked it.
I was like,
that is a good odds.
What kind of support are you getting
from the party itself?
Oh,
was good as it can be.
I mean,
look,
it's New York State Libertarians.
There aren't that many of them to small
party.
Uh,
there are city,
two counties in New York.
We have about 20 affiliates,
so we have 42 counties that didn't have
affiliates.
So it's,
it's not a powerful party to across the
state.
We not even officially a party were
officially a committee.
What do you mean?
Yes,
but I,
I,
the,
the parties autonomous at behind me.
One hundred percent.
There isn't that much there.
What they can do,
they are doing.
I'm very happy with what they're doing.
I wish I'd had a party.
I wish had more bodies.
I do.
I wish I had more bodies,
but luckily getting there we are and
we're getting more people from other
states are coming.
Also other people are joining and for
the first time now people are coming to
the party because of me,
right.
Most people who join me before came to
the party because of someone else.
Ron,
Paul,
Gary Johnson,
Harry Brown,
and then so my candidacy.
I jumped on board,
but now that I've been so active for so
many months in New York state,
some people not coming to partly because
of me.
Those people are now building up our
group of,
of,
of uh,
of activists.
So I am getting more and more again,
what I'm getting from the people is
amazing.
I do more of them though.
So we are getting there.
Do you sense that there is a rebirth of
liberty in this country in general?
I mean,
I can tell from what I'm out now on the
road and touring and the response I get
to this show and the amount of emails I
get in twitter that people are talking
about liberty.
Again,
they're talking about it's not just the
tea party anymore.
Talking about liberty,
about liberty,
talking about freedom.
You talk about the founding documents.
People are actually reinvigorated about
this stuff.
What moves people is two things.
One,
they feel like things are so broken and
then to someone gives them hope.
Revolutions as they say installed,
was it built on?
Hope?
They are.
It's true,
right?
The,
the Russians stayed,
what?
Three hundred years being oppressed,
whatever it was,
foreign ears being oppressive as
peasants and serves and so there was
some hope.
Then the communist gave them hope and
they revolted.
It has to be hope,
but it wasn't a communist.
Countries might have been around for a
bit.
It was London,
right?
It was an individual.
People bring people to revolutions.
People give other people hope.
We're finding better messengers now than
we've ever had.
It's not just rumble,
right?
It's a lot of us are doing this and I'm
hoping if you've seen my campaign,
I'm doing my best.
Half of my team is not in New York.
That's on purpose,
so a purpose because I want to make sure
that my [inaudible] seven directors and
about 50 active volunteers and about 200
and winks and I'm purposely doing that
because I want people to be able to grow
that infrastructure so that in 2020 we
have seven campaign managers,
active campaign.
We run a real campaign who not do things
like this who don't make things work.
The betrayal part is not happening.
Infrastructure we needed.
If we have better infrastructure,
we have more people like me who want to
do this.
Right.
People don't run because they have to
run by themselves.
So infrastructure.
Yeah,
but now I can say,
no,
no.
Here's your team.
Better people will run and they'll run
better candidacies that run better
campaigns and when they do that,
more people will see them,
will be more people to the movement.
I think there is a rise,
but it's because we're having better
candidates.
Are you tracking Austin Petersen out in
Missouri?
I'm a fan,
but he's been here.
We're friends.
I think he's doing great work.
Last I saw a poll just in the last
couple of weeks.
I mean,
it looks like he's beaming mccaskill.
I,
I think that's one of the type of ones
and Ben potentially years as well that I
agree with you in that for sure.
That it's like,
man,
if one of these guys breakthrough,
I just wish he put an elbow to his name.
So I think he had.
Well I think he first,
you know,
he definitely is a libertarian.
There's no doubt about that.
And I think,
yeah,
I'm a fan.
Yes.
Doing forward.
I'm on record.
I was,
I was probably the only guy on the,
on the,
uh,
in the living and leadership who said
please stay.
I openly what I call them.
I want them to stay.
I wanted him to stay.
And what did,
what did he say to that?
Is it just real politic?
So Joseph,
he's like,
look,
everyone's telling me to.
You're like,
you're like one of the only guys telling
me to go libertarian.
Yeah.
I was one of the only guy.
It's true.
So at the end of the day,
I still want to be a libertarian,
but at the end of the day,
you still want them to win.
Of course.
Clearly,
yes.
Feel yes,
of course.
I wanted to win.
Yes.
When I'd rather have him on mccaskill
and Senate.
It's not even close.
Not even close.
Of course not.
Of course I wanna know what I.
I'm asking them.
Of course.
I want him to win.
Yes.
I Miss Saying,
Oh God,
I'm selfish.
I'd rather them have nobody's name,
but I'll take him an hour.
Oh,
Saito.
I'll deal.
I'll deal with them in our LLC.
So I'll tell you one of my fears about
what could potentially happen with the
libertarians because I do.
You can see I'm with you on on so much
of this stuff.
And even though again,
as I call myself a classical liberal,
there's plenty of room for agreement
here.
Okay,
great.
And where there is,
where there might be little
disagreement.
That's rich,
right?
Well that's a great place to do.
Okay.
What I'm a little concerned about is
that the movement of liberty is going to
grow and grow and grow.
It's going to be real nice.
You'll probably do pretty well if,
if not when you'll do pretty well.
Austin,
if not when will do pretty well.
I think there were a couple other
candidates around that are going to do
pretty well and then it will grow into
something that nationally come 20,
20 is going to be actually more viable
than it was even under Gary Johnson.
They'll get someone that's probably
younger and more tech savvy and
whatever.
It'll be someone kind of cool and uh,
and that they are going to then take
like they're going to pull it some
unheard of number for libertarians out
of national level,
something like 15 percent.
And we're gonna win electoral votes in
20,
20.
So all good.
We are going to an electoral votes.
So I'm with Ya and I agree,
but do you see why I see the danger
there too was dangerous.
The oncoming danger would be that you'd
be pulling all of those votes from the
right and that you end up help.
Now I know this is not a defense of the
right and I got what I what if you then
end up with some.
Seriously good.
Yeah.
Good.
Sell me on this very clear.
We have two choices.
Option one,
stay in this slow road to oblivion,
which is where we're going now or shake
things up and get them to happen here.
Someone asked where the night I was at
an event.
I was at a,
um,
a sportsman's event of the night in
Suffolk County last night.
And the guy said,
well,
Larry,
we have,
what if you take a lot from the
Republican?
I said,
I hope I tear him to pieces.
I hope I,
I hope he gets five percent.
Oh my God.
What happened?
Then Republicans will learn their lesson
and have to be Republicans.
They can't be Democrat lite anymore.
Good.
I hope.
I hope that happens.
Let it happen.
I don't care.
Oh,
the Democrats get killed.
Get that smashed.
Good.
Maybe we don't have to care about civil
liberties.
If Libertarians do well,
regardless of who's crushed,
whoever gets crushed,
their lesson has to be learned or they
disappear.
They disappear.
We replaced them.
Awesome.
They don't disappear.
They get better.
There's nothing but good.
I asked crushing either side or both.
Well,
I guess whatever the Republicans.
So what?
There'll be better Republicans,
Democrats.
So what they'll be,
but Democrats.
It doesn't matter.
Yeah,
I guess it's the hammer that you
ultimately need.
That's correct.
My,
my fear would be that then because I
believe the left has gone so far left
that the idea of potentially helping
them put in policies that would be a 180
degrees from everything you just said
there.
That would put in all the deblazio stuff
that you hate in New York City and all
that.
That I would really,
really fear that,
but you just view it as almost a
necessary evil to myself.
Now you're assuming that when this
happens,
people jump on board.
They don't.
They give up [inaudible].
New York is an example of that.
Seventy percent don't vote.
The people don't actually like these
ideas.
They've given up.
They think there's no hope.
So they've given up.
Guess what?
Here comes,
Mr.
Hope this opens the door for me so it
happens.
And Twenty,
20 libertarians are amazing and we
crushed the right it does happen.
And as a whatever Bernie is the
president,
whatever the case may be,
all the people have no hope.
When 20,
22 comes around for the,
for the,
um,
Senate races and for the House races,
you will watch libertarians say,
see what happened,
hope.
And you will watch a sleeping a power in
22 and then 20,
24,
boom.
You'll watch the presidency.
Good,
good and Democrat to be afraid of.
They won't.
The other thing,
we know everything and they'll lose it.
The loss of Hillary,
that was that we know everything and
trump beat them.
Or they'll change either way too when I
have no worries.
Yes,
I hope you're right.
I don't care which one happens.
Crush both.
Crush either is irrelevant.
It's the right answer.
It's the only way you make the change.
Whenever you have to have positive
change,
there has to be some disruption.
And we're afraid of disruption.
You can't.
Let's just let people know that it will
be disruption.
Let's hold their hand through it and
boom it besides.
Awesome.
Alright,
let's just knock out a couple of
policies and then uh,
then I send you back to New York to get
cracking.
I do,
I worked with.
Yeah.
Um,
okay.
So I think on the drug stuff,
marijuana,
you're for legalization,
correct.
Not just marijuana,
but also hemp and I want it to be
regulated.
As I say this all the time for farmers
like onions,
I don't want to write new rules and
regulations that will take forever.
I want us to take onions,
cut and paste,
hemp marijuana go.
And the reason why I want that is our
farmers in New York state are struggling
desperately,
so why don't we allow them.
If they want you to grow hemp,
to grow marijuana,
they want to enjoy.
Go ahead,
do what they want,
but not just that.
People talking about marijuana and
cannabis products as being expensive and
taxed.
If it's regular,
like onions grow in your backyard,
don't care growing your back yard will
allow.
How do we celebrate a tax the hell out
of it?
No.
Then we create a black market,
which we have now officially you can get
medical marijuana in New York officially
you can one place in New York City and a
massive black market.
Right?
So instead like helpful sor seller,
like you know what?
It's helpful store,
but a regulation.
There's no relation to health plus those
either.
We're all the desks from all the health
was.
Well GNC got so whatever.
They're all the desks.
None.
I think I went over the data with data
and create a team maybe once we go for
hitting the gym a long time ago.
So the FDA has killed far more people
than every health food store ever
created.
So really like that.
So it's fine.
Put a thing,
not regular by FDA.
Good luck.
Whatever.
I don't care.
Do what you want.
Uh,
let's just do a couple of other hot
button ones.
So a guns where you at?
What does that mean?
While we were yet know if people in New
York City itself want farm where
treatment?
Yeah,
that's fine.
The fact it's a big deal in New York
that you may or may not know what the
safe act came out after sandy hook and
it basically made a bunch of equipment
illegal,
so it made a bunch of people who own
firearms legally,
criminals overnight,
and now they put you in jail and not
just that.
If you have a magazine,
have a member of the rule,
right?
If you're a magazine can fit 11 rounds
in it,
you,
you are now a violent felon according to
state law to Baba Felon.
That's how bad is.
The safe act is terrible and now we're
talking about idea of taking guns for
people.
So I told you if the children in school
with he did,
he says that the child is a problem
child.
They go take your guns if you're
mentally ill to your guns and they in
New York state includes,
if you're transgendered,
she don't get to have guns.
If you're transgender in New York state.
I mean it's embarrassing how bad this
thing is.
It's terrible.
That has to be repealed.
I can't repeal the law.
I'm the governor.
So I knew it was like the beginning of,
pardon people who were convicted of it,
but a thousand people in New York state
have convicted of safe act.
I'm a infringements about about a
thousand.
I'll begin partnering them within the
First Ninety days.
So we have people in jail in New York
right now who were doing something
completely legally.
The law change.
And then they were put in jail.
That correct that.
That is incredible.
Yes,
that's correct.
And it's guns,
therefore it's evil.
Yeah.
Remember how New York state works and
York state works.
It's evil.
Hit it with a stick.
That's our first always first reaction.
What is that?
He with a stick.
So we do.
So yes.
That's true.
Actually met James Time at the first guy
who got his first conviction.
He's a three time convicted felon I
think,
if not mistaken.
So I'll be in pardoning when I sought to
pardon.
That will let people know I'm serious.
Stop.
That was going to happen when I pardon.
Reason why people don't pardon early is
because what's going to happen when I
pardon a hundred people?
What I'm gonna do something stupid.
They're going to go rob a liquor store
or a car or whatever,
do something bad,
beat their spouse,
insert thing here.
What are they going to do?
I get it's going to happen and when it
happens,
they're going to blame me.
I'm going to say,
governor sharp.
You already have a guy.
This liquor store got robbed because you
let a guy out because he was a violent
felon and I'm going to say several
things.
One,
I don't care when I.
When everyone's gonna hate me.
I'm going to be attacked everyday by the
assembly everyday by the Senate.
Everyday by the press,
I'm going to have an assembly and the
Senate.
That's completely against me.
That's one of a bazillion things.
Won't care,
but not just that.
Yes.
One guy did something wrong.
Put that guy in jail for that.
I even had people write that they got
off and our nation was built on the idea
that it would be better for a guilty
person,
go free than an innocent person to be in
prison will get 99 out.
I'm okay with that and when I do that,
the assembly will see that I will take
the heat for them and when they see that
in 2019 they'll repeal in 20 slash 20
because I've given them the air cover
and on top of that I'm going to veto any
bill that has any safe act enforcement
funding gone.
They won't bother putting it in because
I'll veto it and they will now have to
double down on it as a separate piece
that will crush them on the right.
They won't do it,
so that means you will not be enforced
and I'll begin and I will actually be in
pardoning people as they get arrested.
Prosecutors love it.
Easy going.
Easy conviction.
Cops hated the cops will love that I'm
not enforcing anymore and they will
happily on it.
It becomes useless in 2019 gets repealed
in 2020.
By the way,
I copy the same model for marijuana
laws.
Same model,
same thing.
Begin begin to a pardon.
People who are convicted of nonviolent
marijuana possessions.
Stop enforcing it.
Same idea,
same concept.
They see how it works.
Twenty,
20,
repealed.
Yeah,
it's just incredible.
You found and I followed that by the
way,
the,
the veto and that model is the Gary
Johnson model.
Alright.
GimMe Gimme.
One more thing.
That's an important issue to you before
we were at.
There's tons of them,
but those are good.
I mentioned the other one,
the vaping,
the Duis.
I mentioned that also.
I'm also the biggest idea though of all
of them is the unfunded mandate.
We have to localize government.
If we take away,
if we take away the unfunded mandates
now individual counties can decide.
In Baltimore they want people to say the
same thing,
but Larry,
if that happens then I won't get what I
want.
Now you can just show them before if you
like what your county's doing.
Don't change a thing.
Show up,
vote yes on everything and you're good,
but if you don't,
you can change it.
That's really the key to libertarianism.
You might have to be involved.
You might show up and talk to your
neighbor and tell them why you care
about a certain policy or issue.
You might have to care about stuff.
Yes.
Larry can't someone else do it.
They couldn't do it.
Now the other thing is a sale time,
but laterally dead Kennedys will make
arrows.
They'll make mistakes and fail.
Yes,
but we're all failing.
Now.
The state's bleeding to death.
I want to follow the Google model.
The Google model says,
20 percent of your time can be used in
whatever you want as long as you're
transparent until but as what you're
doing.
Counties do what you want.
However we want to vote,
but transparency of almost see what's
happening.
We do that.
What happens?
Some fail,
some succeed,
but we then learn what works and what
doesn't.
We shift and adjust regions.
We'll figure out what works for each
region and we'll actually have
improvement.
This,
this disruption that happens before you
have success,
that's happens in business.
It happens in every and habits in life,
everything,
so we do that,
become a sharing state,
sharing economy.
We change how things work.
Being on top of that,
that's one part.
The second thing you do is you add
what's called a charitable choice credit
for your taxes.
What that is is 20 bucks.
That would be your tax money going to
the tax man anyway,
your choice.
You can give it to a nonprofit if you
want to,
if you want to.
It's going out of your pocket anyway.
You want to go to a nonprofit,
you can plus another 2:50
in your own county.
So if I were in a box of your money into
your accounting for the sake of argument
in this area,
there are 40,000
people who pay taxes.
That's 2 million possible dollars
voluntary.
If you want to do it,
do it again.
If you like your government,
don't change it.
Don't do it.
You got it,
you're good.
You like it,
but say if it is a better way for
childcare,
besides the only government monopoly,
which is a disaster,
maybe is a better way for a glen roads,
which government is a disaster.
There's a better way.
A private company now can lobby you,
not the government because you give them
money and the more money you give,
the less corruption there is.
Yeah,
I love that.
The more transparency there is let's
crush or it allows the actual counties
to begin to prioritize as they want,
as they see it work.
They can make that more or less or
shift.
This is the beginning part.
I'm talking about showing them that
there's other ways of getting things
done besides government and there's not
a Zombie apocalypse on top of how do I
also raise money or what is the
libertarian responds to the Zombie
Apocalypse?
Uh,
I dunno,
I guess guns clients,
I guess.
Yeah.
So there's another way of raising money
also,
whichever you bring up also.
And that is naming rights on
infrastructure,
right?
The MTA just in New York City is over 12
bridges and tunnels and right now what
we've done in New York state as we've
named one of our bridges after the Cuomo
family,
it's called the marrow Como Bridge.
Now we have which bridges that.
It's what's happened now.
It is now that the imperial bridge of
the imperial family.
So now that has to go instead.
Let's,
let's leave out naming rights.
Could be the verizon bridge,
this sprint bridge,
the staples bridge,
the home depot breach.
I don't care.
You pick the person who wants it.
Right.
The company wants it now.
They do this for already for stadiums.
They pay 10,
20,
$30,000,000
a year for something used half a year.
This is a bridge they can choose every
day.
Your name gets mentioned a hundred times
at least every morning.
Afternoon during rush hour on every
radio station in a 16 million person
metro area.
You're telling me companies that paid
literally billions of dollars in
marketing every year went up
$100,000,000
in a bridge,
but here's a rule,
no tolls,
actual break for people and they control
maintenance.
If they control maintenance,
guess what?
No more corruption in the maintenance
industry anymore because now sprints
paying for not the government,
no more closing lanes at the closing
lanes in bw.
Bridge goes away.
Sprints,
I can put up with it.
There's potholes,
sprints.
I can put up with it.
They'll follow you so you.
Yeah.
These are different ideas that people
that we have.
The Erie Canal in New York state,
it's about 500 and some odd miles of
Erie canal.
We can name the locks.
It's about three dozen blocks in blocks,
all different ideas.
There's so many ways of raising money
and changing how we look at this and
they're not perfect by any means,
but there are conversations we need to
be having to ship this idea that the
only way to civilization and taxation,
it isn't the only way.
It's a way.
It's not the only way.
There were other options available and
people just don't get it.
You open this up.
I believe that all the time they love
it,
that you ended up.
You Go,
oh,
it's great.
I like that idea and we try that.
Someone is gonna be tried.
This is what we want to do.
We shift the Way New York state runs and
the rest of the nation will follow.
If I just beat the Republican,
everyone will hear what I have to say.
I've been every TV show in the country.
They will hear what I have to say.
They'll hear this.
They'll start telling their people,
they'll start copying.
This campaign has the most possibility
for impact than any other campaign in
2018,
and here's what I promise you.
If I raised $2,000,000
on the governor,
it's that simple.
2 million bucks on the governor.
Done well.
I've enjoyed this conversation.
I think you've got the right set of
ideas and I look forward to seeing what
happens.
Good,
and now I'm going to send people to your
website because I assume you got a
doughnut,
but Larry sharp.com
lottery shot with an ie.
The e stands for electrical.
Now I know you're really running because
he even pimped out the website telling
Larry sharp.com.